handball name ist meine linie freut ich
darf euch heute mal wieder recht
herzlich willkommen heißen zu einer
neuen aktie auf tour zu ende meiner
letzten session of two hände waren wir
an der stelle stehen geblieben wo die
teilnehmer diese uhr erhalten haben wenn
die leds auf dieser uhr normal schwarz
sind geld noch die normalen regeln also
dass man nichts irgendwie mit anderen
leuten haben darf die zkb allerdings
können diese leds auch grün werden und
dann darf er mit der anderen person rom
lecken oder kuscheln oder keine ahnung
was also wir schauen mal weiter ich spät
[Applaus]
die spätzeit für mehr echte verbindung
da geht es direkt intelligenz geladen
los heißt es dass du aufstehst
bevor man sich gleich meldet ganz kurze
zwischenfrage von mir francescas steht
oft als ich dachte francesca steht auf
harry oder auf mich francesca wann kommt
eigentlich mal hallo ladies endlich die
störung problem
francesca ich habe ein date für dich und
kelz arrangiert was
hey francesca weiß kerzers du aufstehst
auf wahrscheinlich ist ernst aber so
völlig rennen haben sich darüber
unterhalten und jetzt zu ja ich hab date
für euch ich hoffe dein make up ist
wasserfest
was war du siehst die als meister fest
andere reden ist nicht übel
so würde ich mich auch mal gern sehen
das sind jeden abend mit einer pizza auf
dem sofa hatten case und echte chance
uns zu küssen muss die regeln zu brechen
nur noch geil dass sie sich sorgen macht
um regel brechen deshalb weil sie bisher
die einzigen beiden verstöße verschuldet
hat halo fans was ich biete dir die
chance auf ein date mit francesca who
wahrscheinlich kriegt er jetzt aber eine
vorgabe die er sich halten muss oder
irgendwie so ob nimmst du das angebot an
wer nicht was
ende
wo also ich würde dann einspringen
ja ich bin ich hätte auch hätte ich
hätte ich auch keine zeit gehabt alter
ich wurde aber kurz mal in badehose aber
ich muss standhaft bleiben wenn die
regeln halten und mit gutem beispiel
vorangehen sonst wäre ich ein heuchler
das stimmt pelz ist ja der buch.de ist
egal auf jeden fall hält sie ganz auf
alle rum gemeckert von wegen dürfen
keine regeln brechen aber er geht jetzt
in francesca in hot ab
ich bin auch ich kann rein springen die
frau die maßgeblich am schrumpfen der
resort kasse beteiligt war und der mann
der auf keinen fall geld verlieren will
haben ein denk danke danke dass ich hier
alleine sitze und nicht da netflix
übrigens falls sie noch leben die leute
braucht es zu heiß ich hätte gerne die
habe er hat wahrscheinlich hast du das
vegane dass er vorbereitet chaos also
jetzt ist ja wirklich hier ist ja
eigentlich das date vor allem das oben
[Musik]
war völlig klar dass harry dann
plötzlich durchs bild läuft ganz random
wie konnte das passieren
ich hatte die heißt es dass im juli
tamir sorgen und jetzt flirtet sie mit
ihrem typ der hässlicher ist als ich
naja harry
ich sehe mich da eigentlich mit chelsea
ja die reden sollten ja meinten eine
stärke wieder wahrscheinlich sehe ich
mich damit kerze im whirlpool egal
wahrscheinlich macht zum nächst außen
und den schildern und ist das mit terry
vorbei pelz geht direkt auf ganze ist es
mit harry vorbei
vor allem die hatten doch auch gar
nichts ändert sich doch noch einmal
geküsst oder nach hatten sie die ganze
zeit streit oder harry hat es eine
chance ja hat dies jetzt bin ich dran
bin ich schon swiss das stimmt harry
hatte halt wirklich seine chance und
herr zeit voll verkackt dadurch dass er
francesca vor allem bloßgestellt hat und
gesagt hat dass sie ihn geküsst hat was
aber nicht stimmt
doch sehr komisch die action crime dass
nicht jemand mal auf diese serie wäre
dass wir uns unterhalten so eine
reality-tv-show es waren auch alle gegen
romeo und julia
das ist eine böse aber die hatten spaß
egal was die anderen leute das sehe ich
auch so
vergleich einfach mit romeo und julia
harry und francesca tab pelz und
francesca damm whirlpools aber was ist
los mit einer birne heute ich hätte gern
grünes licht mache ich auch ohne
was
das wäre der absolute
wenn francesca jetzt für das wäre viel
zu krass wenn francesca dann für alle
drei regelverstöße bisher verantwortlich
wäre
als anderer teilnehmer würde ich mir
denken francesca bitte schnapp dem
paddelboot und paddel nach timbuktu du
bist hi
hey bis zu drei riesen verlieren
francesca
du brichst jetzt bitte mich noch eine
regel sollte die uhr doch grün leuchten
fürchte ich ernsthaft um kells
sicherheit
macht es mir schwer das ich und ich bin
ja
und er fragt sie ob sie grünes licht
sehr gute einstellung aber nur leuchtet
immer noch nicht frei ihr dürft nicht
egal wann pausiert er guckt immer
komisch während manchester nicht locker
lässt im keller doch noch um zu kriegen
ist es unlogisch dass sie nicht mal dein
spiegelbild aufheitern kann was aber
wenigstens hatte einen leidensgenossen
meine damen der letzten folge halb
verlassen wurde
rechtlich ist es so
daran wird sich bestimmt auf die
schenkel klopfen wenn herr hochhuth an
[Musik]
festival hat schon wieder ein date mit
langsam geht es aber vorrat in der
sendung zwischen uns war von anfang an
etwas aber ich wusste nicht was ist dann
der workshop war eigentlich keinen stock
sondern shop als mayuka sowas hat noch
nie jemand zu mir gesagt was und es war
als würde mich endlich jemand wirklich
sehen
[Musik]
ganz komische folge war wieder ich muss
euch das leider zensieren was sie da
sagen weil werbe freundlichkeit videos
wahrscheinlich eh auf gelb und ich
verdiene wieder keinen cent länder danke
youtube das problem ist nur wann ist
mein freund
ich stand von anfang an auf dich jetzt
es da noch mehr
ich will nicht dass jemand verletzt wird
ich auch nicht
hey das ist eine richtig gute folge
bisher kelz hat francesca den kuss
abgelehnt und wie heißt der typ ich
vergesse es die ganze zeit frank oder so
auf jeden fall hat er jetzt auf honda
gesagt er kann nicht mit ihr eine
tiefere bindung eingehen und weil honda
zuerst menschen vorbei und schon ist ein
freund von ihm
ihr seid krank drauf in dieser folgt ich
bin richtig stolz auf die jungs ich
glaube wenn ich es mit david versuche
kann aus uns was werden kann ist jetzt
schon klar dass es deutlich schwieriger
wird eine beziehung aufzubauen was
überlegen sein erster gedanke hat er
gesagt
weil es da schwierig wird jetzt aus zu
weichen auf einen anderen typen
a
zwickmühle wer hat dich eigentlich ist
ohne motto überlegt was ist eine mühle
die zwickt oder was mache ich nur mit
sharon alles ist so verzwickt schwierig
müssen reden reden ist glaube ich das
beste in der st es ist nur das glas das
auge mit dem glas das erlaubt eine
zwickmühle situation oft zwickende zu
sagen oh gott
ich sehe schon dass demnächst karlsruhe
francesca duschen werden allerdings
würde ich sagen dass wir uns das in
meiner nächsten tor zu henry action in
drei tagen anschauen meine lieben
freunde wenn ihr das nicht wollt dann
lasst unbedingt einen daumen hoch unter
dem video
53.000 like jetzt weiter mitteilte
handle wenn ihr bock habt also lasst
neigt er folgt auf instagram wir müssen
irgendwann mal die drei millionen voll
machen damit ich hier der von ceska
schreiben kann
daumen hoch unser video und auch er
allerdings befinden wir uns jetzt auch
schon der handke einer lieben freundin
zwei die eingeblendet werden noch kein
abonnent von meinem kanal sondern klickt
dann ganz schnell drauf ganz wichtig
beim kanal abonnieren kostenlos da passt
keine videos mehr und hier anderes video
anschauen
ja
[Musik]